previously on council of geeks huh
i won't have to talk about my very
complicated feelings about clara for a
long time after this one
oh that's nice okay look in my defense i
actually shot that
months ago
[Music]
[Music]
clara clara clara i feel pretty safe in
saying that she is the most divisive
companion
of modern doctor who not to say that
every other companion is universally
loved but
i feel like the extremes to which people
either love
or hate clara are harsher and there
seems to be
way fewer people in the middle i don't
know many doctor who fans with a neutral
opinion
on clara oswalt i mean
i'm certainly not neutral on the matter
and while
i'm going to do my best to be fair in
this video
this is not going to be about presenting
both sides of an argument because
frankly i feel like i don't really fully
understand the other side
that being said there is one thing that
i do get
i get the appeal of jenna coleman as an
actress
she's magnetic she's able to do quick
witty dialogue with the best of them
and i can safely say that i won't be
attacking her actual performance
as is usually the case when i get huffy
about doctor who the issue is with
the writing so that's what i'll be
focusing on
so if you personally fell in love with
clara because you basically fell in love
with
jenna as a presence i can understand
that
but for me while i can acknowledge that
it's not enough
when the writing is all over the shop
the impression i've had for a while now
is that showrunner stephen moffat
fell in love with his own fictional
creation i can't
prove this of course nor do i expect
anyone else to accept it as
gospel but that really is the vibe just
coming off the character when you look
at the entire run
now the term mary sue gets banned about
way way
way too liberally these days in the
discourse but strictly speaking i don't
think
clara would qualify because i never got
that sense of author surrogate that's
actually fairly core to a true mary sue
however some of the issues with those
kinds of characters are
present in how clara is written as
presented initially in the latter half
of series 7
she seems to be nearly devoid of flaws
and her characterization changes from
episode to episode depending on what
will best suit the given story
and virtually everyone she meets takes
to her immediately
coleman does manage to paper over some
of this with bringing a very consistent
energy to the character but let's be
honest about it in series 7 clara isn't
really a character she's a plot device
and part of what's annoying about this
is by the time she actually shows up
we've already seen two better versions
of her both
oswin from asylum of the daleks and the
governess from the snowmen
are far more fleshed out characters than
the version of claro we actually travel
with at least for the
remainder of series seven the amount of
information
context clues that we get about these
earlier versions
that we see in their single appearances
completely outstrips
the primary version of clara we know
osmond is a computer genius she signed
up with a starliner company
so we're also kind of getting a little
twinge of like astrid from
voyage of the dam she's practical she
finds comfort in baking she's flirty the
governess
is curious inquisitive good with
children leading a double life
under the nose of her employer to the
point of even changing her accent
depending on who she's interacting with
and clara oswalt who actually travels
with the doctor
watches two kids but doesn't really seem
to have a particularly close bond with
them or with their father
and this is on top of the fact that for
someone like me
who has been begging for a companion
who isn't from contemporary earth for
years
she's already inherently less
interesting than the versions of her
from the future
or from the past and we can't assume
that anything we learned about the other
versions of clara
would apply here because there doesn't
seem to be a lot of carry over from one
incarnation to the other
other than that general energy in the
fast talking
the clara we get isn't good with
computers well not at the start anyway
she's not leading a double life she
doesn't even really seem to have that
inquisitive nature
she's a bizarre mix of having an
expressive personality
while being severely under characterized
again
at least in series seven i mean even
when we learn more about our history
with something like
rings of acatan it's just bullet points
on a biography
the information we learn about her
parents tells us very
little about her as a person
the problems with clara in series 7
are the inevitable consequence of moffat
deciding that the mystery box element
for the second half of the series would
be the companion
quick reminder mystery box is a term i
use for the series arc format that
modern era doctor who has been using
since the beginning it's the recurring
use of an image
or phrase that's repeated across the
series but doesn't have
full meaning until it gets explained
usually in the finale
so think bad wolf vote saxon
the cracks in time the hybrid the
timeless child etc
nearly every modern era series of doctor
who has done
some version of this and the twist here
is that the mystery box isn't a phrase
it's a person well it's also a phrase
because the whole
repeat of the the impossible girl but
you get what i'm saying one can see how
the kernel of the idea
hey let's make the mystery box a
character
might have held some appeal but in
practice because the lid has to be kept
on what's actually going
on up until the end it means the
character doesn't really get to be
a character if we feel like we know her
that would soften the mystery so we
really
don't get to know her very well at all
in that first series that she's in
and this next point is extremely
subjective i admit but
she just didn't have the best chemistry
with matt smith it isn't
awful and honestly part of it is the
fact that smith is having to play up the
whole
she's so mysterious i have to figure her
out angle which
it makes genuine inter-character
connection difficult in the first place
then the on-screen chemistry between
coleman and capaldi being almost
instantly stronger in their dynamic
feeling genuine and lived and rather
than the two keeping each other at arm's
length really
brought the issue of series seven and
the lack of chemistry into sharp focus
for me
okay but okay series seven didn't really
have a character in clara
it had a character-shaped macguffin but
that wasn't the case
subsequent series and i've already
copped to her dynamic with capaldi being
better besides she'd hardly be the first
companion to have a bit of a rough start
donna noble is my favorite companion of
the modern era
despite me finding very little to like
about her performance in the runaway
bride so
did things get better in series eight
yes a bit giving clara a clear life
outside of the doctor
you know with a job a boyfriend honestly
it did wonders to flesh her out as a
character
and make her feel like an actual human
being now the funny thing is
normally i would bemoan the earthbound
domestics
but clara kinda needed it after a half
series of being so nebulous
before series eight all we really had to
was this sort of
odd babysitter relationship she had with
the kids but there didn't feel like
there was much history or investment
there
and her odd relationship with the doctor
didn't feel like a proper
bond either for the reasons i already
mentioned so in series eight we get to
see her
in teacher mode and we get to see how
that
mindset influences her interaction with
the doctor
and others and danny pink okay so
danny's a
little bit of a mixed blessing on the
one hand by giving clara another
character to interact with on a regular
basis
we get a much better sense of her as a
person we watch as she
kind of jerks danny around takes him for
granted
repeatedly lies to him even after he
knows who the doctor
is so the only person she's protecting
at that point is herself
so this is what i mean by mixed bag
these are character traits but it also
doesn't exactly paint her as a
particularly good person now
that not need inherently be a big
problem companions
don't have to be perfect people and
honestly it'd be kind of boring if they
were
the issue here is one of framing because
while we watch
clara lie to danny's face and we see her
do it over and over and over and over
again
the show never really seems to think
that this is a bad thing
it's often treated in frame more as some
kind of amusing complication of her life
as opposed to a repeated betrayal of
another human being's trust
it has the playful tone of donna not
telling her mother about the doctor but
again
pretty quickly danny knows who the
doctor is
so it's not oh i just won't tell him she
has to actively
and consciously decide to deceive him
over and over and over again
she is putting her life in danger on a
regular basis this is not
something he doesn't need to know it's
something he has a right to know as her
partner
and is actually asking her about
now i suspect some of you are saying
isn't that more of a danny
problem than a clara problem not
really because the two are intertwined
and interconnected
and it also doesn't help that the
resolution of series a kind of hinges on
the strength of their relationship
strength that has been getting undercut
at every step
when clara threatens to throw the tardis
keys into the lava it doesn't read as
somebody desperate to bring back the
person they love
it reads as someone who just can't deal
with something
anything happening that she didn't have
control or say over
which again is a character trait and a
flaw and that's fine
but then the story banks on the fullness
of their love and it just doesn't
track because the show never properly
grapples
with just how one-sided their
relationship actually
is given that i've
just touched on the end of series 8 i
feel like this is a good time to address
how many times clara was set up to exit
the show and then
just didn't starts with a fantastic
scene where the doctor and clara both
lie to each other and then they part
ways
neither in a state where they are able
to continue journeying
with the other and it has been confirmed
that this was originally written as an
exit point for clara though before
production started
jenna coleman decided to stay on board
this would be the first of
two times that she would almost leave
the show
as then last christmas was also written
as her exit only to have her change her
mind and stay after the table read
now this i'm ready to leave no
wait i'll stay thing especially twice in
a row
is pretty much the one item that i'm
going to hold
jenna coleman culpable for and all this
now if this had happened in an american
show
it would have been a very safe bet that
the actor was just saying they're
leaving in order
to try and squeeze out a pay increase in
order to keep them around but
tv production culture in the uk isn't
really the same
beast and i never got that impression
and i
do believe that she really did genuinely
feel torn about leaving
and changed her mind which
okay that happens
but it still does have a tangible impact
on the show
death in heaven felt largely unaltered
it really did read like they just kept
the she's not coming back script
as it already was since the ending
wasn't quite so firm that they couldn't
in fact roll it back and have a return
and have her return and appear again
last christmas on the other hand is a
bit of
a mess toward the end now stephen moffat
claims he wrote two versions right from
the start
suspecting she might change her mind
again and to be honest
i have a really hard time believing that
because after a really well done
heartfelt resolution to clara's time
with the doctor and giving her a full
life without him
the no wait she's fine more adventures
ending
feels nothing if not stapled on after
the fact
and the thing is i'm actually trying to
be nice to moffitt when i say i don't
believe him about always having a
version
ready to go where she stays because
if that's not true and he didn't always
have it it would definitely explain why
it feels like it ends twice
with the second ending added on as
quickly as possible without altering the
rest of the script
but if it's true and he always did have
this one plan then honestly
it means he thought it was better to
fake out and exit and backtrack
immediately rather than do a proper
rework
so that the ending where she stays feels
organic and not tacked on and that is
just
terrible writing and even if i set that
aside and don't get hung up on how weird
and disjointed
the end of last christmas feels this is
still a problem
because it inherently devalues the
tension that would otherwise be inherent
when she actually leaves
you can't keep faking out the audience
and expect the same
impact every day in time is why
character deaths carry no weight in
superhero comics
fool us once shame on you fool us twice
shame on us
try and fool us the same way over and
over and over and over again
how stupid you think i am but okay so
after an undercooked first series but a
stronger yet still flawed second series
with two good exits that didn't turn out
to be exits
we finally got the actual real no
fingers crossed we promise
final series for clara oswald series
nine now here's the thing
series nine nearly won me over on clara
actually i tell a lie series nine did in
fact win me over
it just then lost me again with an
episode that i am going to spend
as little time as humanly possible on
because i've already devoted
three videos and notable portions of
several more to the thing
and i suspect that people are actually
finally tired of hearing me bang on
about it
so here are the two things series nine
did with clara
that are really well thought out
first instead of having clara appeared
to always somehow be in the right even
when she's
clearly not it picked a real
true character flaw and it stuck to it
that doesn't stop the show from still
making her extra smart and clever at the
expense of other characters in a few
instances the most egregious
of which being that nobody in unit
apparently even considered the idea that
airplanes stopped in mid-air could be
used as weapons until clara suggested it
airplanes
4165 aircraft currently airborne
that's a lot of passengers that's a lot
of fuel oh dear god
yes it is this is this is a military
group
operating post 9 11 and nobody thought
of this before the school teacher popped
her head in
but even moments like that don't
completely dampen the work
done on what mother and his team
selected as her big failing
in series 9 clara has not only a clear
flaw but a
tragic and ultimately fatal one and
what's more
it's not one they just plastered on to
or out of nowhere
it's not like how in back to the future
part two suddenly
marty can't stand being called chicken
where the heck was that the first time
no
instead they picked on something that
was already there with clara
it's not just that she wants to travel
with the doctor
she seemed to actually want to be the
doctor it's something that she's learnt
from the doctor and and keeps learning
so i think she's definitely
adopted his point of view and his
attitude
this got dropped a few times in series
eight with episodes like flatline
where she tries to fill the doctor's
role in his absence
by imitating him as best she could and
then it's reinforced in death in heaven
with the whole
at the time was a pretty pointless scene
which appeared to exist only
as a snippet that could be used in
teasers but
now retroactively it becomes something
that is stoking the fire
of her drive to measure up to the doctor
and do the things that he would do
it's a really smart thing to latch onto
so that now
she has a trajectory and a path that
leads to her debt that doesn't feel
unearned or manufactured
the hints are there and they exist in
the previous series now
that she is always on the path to face
the raven it's brought up again
in series nine and under the lake where
the doctor flat out tells her
to not try and be him
and ultimately that's the very thing
that gets her killed
trying to out think the situation doing
what she believes the doctor would do
that is why she died she is so sure that
she is doing the smart thing
certain enough that it's what the doctor
would do she doesn't even
think that she needs to tell him before
she does it
and then she dies from that choice
it's a choice that's built up to it's
treated as a tragedy rather than karmic
retribution
it's unfair but not unprovoked
she didn't deserve this but she still
brought it on herself
and the fact that it happens not in the
finale but with two episodes still to go
was the perfect way to defuse the issue
of two previous near exits
because it swoops in ahead of when fans
would have been prepared for it
adding to the tragedy and the impact of
the whole thing it is
borderline genius
which is ultimately undermined two
episodes later with hell bent and rather
than rehash my issues you can check out
my last video i made on it there's the
thing only bit i want to add on
the topic of that episode is that i know
i know there are people who truly love
hell bent
part of that does seem to depend on how
they feel about clara as a character
people who loved the character even
before that episode airs
do tend to be hell bent defenders
additionally i am aware that some people
feel that i
fundamentally misunderstand not only how
bent which i actually openly admit
i don't get but the two preceding
episodes as well
and while i don't engage with them i
have seen
the essays in my comments so
many essays i've even read most of them
but here's the thing i've yet to hear a
defense of hell bent
that didn't involve a lengthy
explanation of what's really going on
or a ton of head canon work that's
barely supported by the episode's text
or hammering on the issue of moffat's
intent over and over and over again
or more recently insisting that now it's
okay because of stuff that happened in
series 12
and frankly all of it gives me
flashbacks of the people who would shove
a minimum 2000 words down your throat
insisting that if you didn't love
batman v superman dawn of justice then
you don't
get it and they're gonna set you
straight and while
all the defenses that i see share some
common points
they don't all have the same read on the
thing which brings me
to the same sentiment that i have about
bvs
and sucker punch and neon demon and
which i will now say about hell-bent
if a significant portion possibly the
majority of the audience
doesn't get what a piece of art is doing
then that is a failure of the
art part of an artist's job especially
if it's intended for mainstream
consumption
is to convey the ideas they're
addressing and if people come away
not catching those ideas and the
defenders don't all agree on what those
ideas even were then the artist
screwed up
okay i'm done with that so to reiterate
it's less that i hate clara as a
character than it is
her time in the role being a frustration
sandwich
there's a stretch in the middle that's
pretty good but on either end are
massive annoyances that i can't ignore
if clara had exited with face the raven
then my position would be the character
had a weak start it got
better if hell bent still existed and
her first series wasn't as a macguffin
then i would say well good character got
a weak send off
but when you start weak and get better
and then end week
that's how you get the office also clara
oswald
okay that's it i honestly really didn't
want to be tackling this again
so soon but truth be told right after
finishing the series 9 re-watch is
really the
point where it made the most sense to
talk about this but but that that's it
take two doctor who review moves forward
onto the holiday specials and then
series 10
which i like quite a lot first time
around so i hope you will stick with me
and see if that is
still the case and i can hopefully
be done
i would like to be done on this subject
and i know to a certain degree no one is
making me talk about it
and i am doing this to myself but i'm
trying to cleanse my
soul of these things that drive me nuts
i am unburdening myself and if you did
not wish to be the recipient
of that unburdening then i am sorry
but unless somebody tries to set me off
in a live stream going forward
this should be my last word on clara
i've said that before about so many
things and then come back and talk about
stuff again
oh anyways so whatever your thoughts are
on the topic of clara oswald drop
something down in the comments
let's talk about it just be polite not
only to me but to other commenters
there's been an issue lately with people
who seem to be coming into my comment
sections just to start
fights and look if you disagree with me
that's fine leave your comment down
there to
why you think i'm wrong but don't go
scrolling through the comments and
leaving rebuttals on the comments of
everyone who doesn't share your opinion
don't do that
so as long as you can resist yourself
doing that
let's see what folks have to say
i have a patreon that is in fact what
pays my bills
this is my living and any amount you are
able to give
is of great assistance and even if
you're not like share subscribe they all
help me out hit the bell if you feel so
inclined
but you also don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye